[Música]
bienvenidos a 5 minutos con hoy
hablaremos sobre la autorización de la
vacuna the fighter para los jóvenes
entre 12 y 15 años en eeuu una medida
significativa en la lucha contra la
pandemia para hablar de este tema le
damos la bienvenida nuevamente al doctor
oscar franco epidemiólogo director del
instituto de medicina social y
preventiva de la universidad de berna
académico de harvard y de la universidad
erasmo de rotterdam y quien desde hoy
vuelve como nuestro asesor científico
gracias doctor por acompañarnos y que
sigue ahora para la implementación de
esta vacuna en los jóvenes
gracias a ustedes por permitirme
acompañarlos y compartir estas
excelentes noticias ya veíamos hace unos
días como canadá era el primer país que
autorizado a la vacunación en mayores de
12 años y ahora se suma la rda de los
eeuu que la agencia que autoriza los
medicamentos y ahora lo que tenemos que
esperar es que la agencia se cdc que es
la de control de enfermedades de los
estados unidos ya permita su
implementación luego ya sí que todo lo
que son los arreglos organizacionales y
legislativos y aquí en eeuu la
legislación cambia por estado pero
básicamente será un proceso detallado
pero un proceso que yo creo que no va a
ser muy complicado y ya podremos
proteger pronto a los niños doctor que
se puede esperar para los menores de 12
años una vez comience efectivamente la
inoculación
ahora mismo no solamente la vacuna de
países sino también moderna
novavax y también si no va que está
evaluando si estas vacunas sirven para
los niños menores de 12 años en miles de
niños la que va más rápido está ahora
file serif aisalla ha adelantado un
calendario y espera que para septiembre
de este año ya pueda tener la suficiente
información para pedir la autorización
en niños mayores de 2 años y luego en
diciembre para niños de más de 6 meses y
luego ya para finales de este año y
principios del próximo que se tenga una
autorización para todas las personas más
allá de la edad entonces vamos a una
velocidad adecuada las cosas van
avanzando muy bien y esperamos estar
buenas noticias pronto bueno y cómo son
esas evaluaciones en niños es decir los
ensayos clínicos en esta parte de la
población son diferentes a los de los
adultos
sí muchas veces pensamos que los niños
son simplemente personas pequeñas o
adultos pequeños y realmente no tienen
una respuesta inmune diferente hemos
visto que tiene un metabolismo también
diferente y estos ensayos se hacen para
evaluar la dosis los intervalos y el
perfil de seguridad más adecuado para
los niños también hay que tener en
cuenta otras cosas como logística porque
mientras que los adultos ellos son los
que dan la autorización en los niños
tienen que ser los padres y también el
niño se le tiene que tener la
autorización así que es un poco más
complejo evaluar medicamentos y vacunas
en niños bueno y considerando el ritmo
que va esta pandemia realmente se
necesita vacunar a los niños
por supuesto se ha establecido un mito
durante la pandemia es que a los niños
no les da coronavirus o que no lo
transmiten y esto está muy lejos de la
realidad si miramos solamente en eeuu en
la población entre 12 y 17 años esto
equivale al 14 por ciento de los casos
en eeuu que cerca de 2 millones de niños
que se han infectado de estos han
fallecido unos 300 y unos 15.000 han
sido hospitalizados además que un 10 por
ciento están reportando síntomas que van
más allá de cuando pasan el virus así
que es fundamental vacunar a los niños
por otras razones esas razones son
primero proteger a los niños segundo por
la inmunidad colectiva que queremos
alcanzar para proteger a la población y
tercero para evitar que el virus siga
mutando y cambiando entre más lo dejemos
circular entonces más va a mutar y más
va a cambiar y si lo ponemos a estos
niños vamos a poder cortar una de las
vías de circulación del virus bueno y
doctor nos ven padres de familia de esta
hora que podríamos decirles a ellos en
cuanto a si es recomendable o no vacunar
a los menores
el mensaje principal es que hay que
evitar a toda costa de que nos de
coronavirus ya sea también a los
líquidos porque si les da coronavirus no
solamente se enfrentan a unas uno se
efectúa versos muy importantes que
pueden ocurrir de manera aguda pero
también de manera crónica pueden tener
fatiga pueden tener otro tipo de cosas
que les puede afectar en su vida en su
calidad de vida así que es importante
protegerse a sí mismos como padres
vacunarse cuando puedan proteger a los
niños mantener las medidas de precaución
y de higiene no bajar la guardia porque
el virus sigue circulando y apenas se
tenga la vacuna esté disponible para los
niños no dudarlo llevar a los niños a
que se vacunen es importante tener en
cuenta que una vez se tenga la
autorización se han pensado los riesgos
y los beneficios y si la autorización
tiene lugar es porque los beneficios son
mucho mayores que los riesgos pues
doctor muchísimas gracias a ustedes una
vez más por estar con nosotros y nos
vemos próximamente a nuestros
televidentes también continúen con toda
la programación y de france 24 y
france24 puntocom
[Música]